nous retrouvons tout de suite l'un de
nos envoyés spéciaux en ukraine julien
schell da bonjour vous êtes azapo rija
situé dans le sud de l'ukraine non loin
de la crimée il y a eu des bombardements
dans la région julien quelle est la
situation ce vendredi matin
alors effectivement fille nommée des
bombardements ont étaient entendus dans
la région de zap aurait déjà alors il
faut préciser que c'est une très grande
région la ville où nous nous trouvons
qui est une métropole d'environ 700
mille habitants elle n'a pas été touché
ni cette nuit ni hier elle a été
contrairement aux autres grandes villes
du pays pour l'instant était épargné par
les bombardements russes mais ce n'est
pas pour ça que c'est pas parce qu'il ya
pas de bombardements ou de chars ou de
d'activités militaires dans cette ville
ce n'est que le spectre de la guerre
n'est pas présent des blessés affluent
de toute part notamment du nord puisque
la ville de tenir qui se trouve au nord
qui est une très grande ville qui se
trouve non loin de deux à pô ridja qui a
été touchée par les bombardements des
blessés affluent de cette ville vers
l'hôpital militaire et la croix rouge
régionales ici demande déjà fait des
appels autant la population du coup
c'est ma deuxième question qu'est ce
qu'on sait du bilan humain quid de sept
blessés quid des déplacés julien
alors c'est toujours la grande question
qui est à laquelle il est très difficile
de répondre dans l'immédiat puisque vous
le savez c'est toujours une guerre de
communication ici dans cette région
entre d'un côté les informations qui
nous viennent de la russie et du côté
ukrainien on sait qu'il ya plusieurs
dizaines de blessés sur le bilan des
victimes pour l'instant je ne peux pas
vous répondre car je n'ai pas de
confirmation sur ce point là mais aussi
déjà qu'il ya des dizaines de blessés et
que l'hôpital militaire est déjà débordé
ici il manque de commandes de produits
médicamenteux de médicaments de produits
de médecine de base ils demandent aussi
à faire
venir du café du thé des choses de la
nourriture extrêmement basique pour
pouvoir subvenir aux besoins des blessés
ici la situation humanitaire risque en
effet de se compliquer julie chide à
quelle est la stratégie des forces
russes dans cette partie de l'ukraine
alors sa stratégie elle inquiète
beaucoup les habitants ici puisque la
vie de dnipro nord a été touché hier à
l'ouest à quelques centaines de
kilomètres c'était la ville d'odessa et
vous le disiez apport et déjà se trouve
peu loin de la crimée où l'on sait que
les troupes russes sont très présents
donc il y à un risque à terme
d'encerclement de la ville ce n'est pas
le scénario qui est encore concrétisé à
l'heure actuelle je vous le répète ici
tout est calme dans la ville mais les
habitants craignent que apport et déjà
ne soit une potentielle cible futur dans
les jours ou les semaines à venir on
sait que les russes ont déjà pris une
centrale électrique qui se trouve à
quelque 200 km au sud de la ville une
prise stratégique qui fait craindre
justement que les russes ne coupent le
courant ou les communications par la
suite ici dans la ville merci beaucoup
julien scheyder envoyé spécial de france
24 à zaporijia dans le sud de la crimée
entre le dombass et dans le sud de
l'ukraine entre le nom basse et la
crimée nous retrouvons maintenant